I think they may have a perception
within the community itself I think the
large events within the community are
not again an opportunity to educate
people within the community and come
down to talking about individual
behavior and individual choices that
people make about their behavior
respecting that and then also respecting
that as a community we want to support
and help each other and not push each
other into harm into harm's way in that
regard so I don't think there's anything
wrong with those gatherings but in
themself I think there are certainly
people who may attend those gatherings
who are doing things that could be
harmful to themselves or others and
people should take responsibility for
that behavior I think it's rampant
because people again people are being
lured into a complacency that use of
chemicals whether it's crystal meth or
other chemicals can somehow get them
through and somehow make their life
easier I have a very close friend that
just came out of rehabilitation from in
a crystal meth program and was one of
the people that did the intervention to
get him into that program to begin with
just a month ago so I know very up close
and very personal the effects of crystal
meth can have on an individual and on
the people who are around that
individual and anybody who may be
watching this who may be having those
problems should get some help and get
some get some support and not be
embarrassed and not be afraid to reach
out for that support